Okay, we're about to let Josh's biggest fans take over
this interview with a little game
we're calling Random Fandom!
(upbeat music)
(Drew laughing)
(audience cheering)
What could go wrong?
(Drew laughing)
Everything! Let's get started.
Hello, Grobanites.
Okay.
We're so glad you're with us today.
Thank you so much for spending your time.
And this lightboard is gonna bounce around,
and we'll see where it lands.
And when it does that person will get
to ask Josh one burning question.
Are you ready? Let's do this!
I feel like the Grobanites are gonna unionize
after this.
(lightboard chimes)
This is like you've made them an official thing
on the Drew Show.
It's almost there.
It's a very long roll, Josh.
(triumphant music)
Are we still rolling?
Oh! (applauding)
(audience applauding)
Oh, my God! Oh, my God! (laughing) (Drew laughing)
Hey!
It's me! (laughing)
Hello!
It's you!
Hello, Drew! Hello, Josh!
What is your name?
Oh, my name is Melissa Fon, and I live in LA as well.
I live in Redondo. Josh, gonna come up and say hello?
(audience giggling)
Yeah, come on over.
I haven't had coffee yet, so I'll make us a cup.
I can bring coffee. I can bring coffee to you.
Ooh, you're in.
Melissa, what is your burning question for Josh?
Oh my God, I could ask you so ready questions.
But aside from your first Grammy performance,
when did you really know you had made it?
Oh, when did I really know I had made it.
That's a really good question.
I don't even think I knew I made it then.
I mean, there are times where I still have to pinch myself,
and I can't believe that I'm in a position
where I get to do what I do.
I think probably the first was when I got to sing
at the winter Olympics in salt Lake city
all those years ago.
And I got to bring my whole family.
I got to bring my parents and my brother.
You know, I always say that this business,
it moves by so fast when it's in you,
and you're just trying to hit every mark that you can
that like when you can bring people with you
that are family,
they can kind of slow down the time for you,
and you can kind of experience it
kind of through their love, and pride, and eyes,
it just makes it really, really special.
So a lot of those experiences
that I had when I was by myself were really great,
but that was the first big thing where I got
to bring my family. And it really kind of made me feel like,
"Okay, all those music lessons have paid off."
Oh my gosh.
Oh, that's great.
Oh no, Melissa, move over.
I might be (indistinct)
Grobanite now.
Thank you, Melissa.
Good luck.
Thank you, Melissa!
And oh, my God,
we love you Josh.
We love you so much.
Thanks, Melissa. I love you right back.
I appreciate it.
(audience cheering)
(Drew clapping) All right, let's roll it again!
(lightboard chiming)
Cause according to the last one,
we're gonna here for a minute.
Do you have a joke? (laughs)
Any good stories there?
Oop, is this-
(triumphant music)
(audience clapping)
Oh!
Are you hearing the horns, the regal horns?
We've got someone.
(Drew laughs)
Regal horns.
Hello. How are you? What is your name?
Hello, how are you? My name is Cheryl.
I'm from New York city.
Ooh. Josh, we need you
New York.
to come back to New York.
I know. I miss it.
New York misses you.
Now winter's thawing, so I'm gonna try and get
back there.
I know.
Now that we can travel again
maybe one day.
I saw you last year
at your Valentine's Day concert at Radio City,
and you were amazing, as always.
Thank you so much. That was such a blast.
Thanks for coming.
My question is, I know you've done Broadway,
you've done concert on stage numerous times.
What is your most embarrassing moment,
either one of those venues?
Sure. I have fallen on my butt a couple of times.
Once on Broadway,
(Drew giggling)
I was in like a kind of a 360 degree show,
so the music pit was in the middle of the stage,
and I played kind of a drunken Russian aristocrat.
So I had to play drunk most of the time.
So, you know, I'm dancing around having a good time,
and I slipped, and I fell onto the drum set,
which kind of actually,
(Drew laughs)
like very naturally made
Oh, my God. (laughs)
like a ba-dum-ching kind of a sound.
And afterwards, you know, you go out at stage door,
and you meet fans outside,
and you're signing playbills and stuff.
And they're like, "That was so method.
That was the most amazing thing that you just...
Do you fall on that drum set every night?"
(Drew and Cheryl laughing)
The key is to sell it well because I had to play drunk, so.
And I was in a padded suit, so that helped.
And it was a matinee of all things.
I mean, I had to do another one.
Oh, no! (laughing)
How do you you get yourself back up after that, you know,
just confidence wise?
Great question, Cheryl.
Thank you so much.
Great, Cheryl.
Thank you having me.
Okay, next Random Fandom!
(lightboard chiming)
Yeah, Josh, I've been there.
There are so many things that happened on Broadway
during the course of a run,
and you try to play it off.
The show must go on.
(triumphant music)
Oh!
Alert!
Yeah. (laughing)
Who goes there?
A message from the king!
(Audience laughing)
(Drew laughing)
Hello? What is your name?
Hello, my name's Jackie from Atlantic City.
Oh!
Jackie from Atlantic City.
My question is, Josh,
I heard you've been quite the cooking concierge
during this lockdown.
What's your new favorite dish to cook?
Oh, I have.
Cooking, I've realized it's something that can be a lot more
than just microwaving.
(Drew laughing)
(audience laugHing)
At 40 years old, I had a microwaving for one cookbook,
and I realized
(Drew laughing)
that cooking is a lot like making music.
You've got all these notes,
you've got all these ingredients.
You don't know how they're gonna shape up.
And I have been trying to support this last year,
a lot of really local farms around here.
And so I'll kind of go online
and find out where there's really great produce and stuff.
And then what I'll do is I'll just kind of get a box
of all kinds of random vegetables.
And then I'll just kind of figure out
how the heck I'm gonna cook them afterwards
because there's no better way to learn how to cook
than to just kind of throw yourself in and figure it out.
So a lot of squash,
a lot corn.
(Drew laughing)
A lot of delicotta up in that house?
That's right, a lot of delicotta, that's right.
Yeah, a lot of shallots.
Yeah, it's been good.
(Drew laughing)
Thank you, Jackie, for your thoughtful question.
(audience applauding)
And I'm not surprised by your answer.
We didn't even get into all your charitable
and philanthropic work.
You're such a good person, Josh.
That's why you deserve Grobanites,
not just for your talents,
Thank you. (laughs)
but you're a good dude.
Well it takes one
to know one.
And it's important.
And I have a quick question, which was,
I know you were doing a residency
at Radio City Music Hall.
And I was wondering, are you planning to pick that up again
at some point?
I am. You know, it's so crazy.
We had spent so much time working on this show
that was gonna go on kind of indefinitely there.
And they kind of gave me the stage to
to just do whatever I wanted.
And it was a variety show.
We did this crazy Valentine's show
with Dr. Ruth and Bridget Everett and all these people.
And it was just a blast.
And then of course it stopped.
So we're gonna pick this bucket back up again in 2022.
(audience cheering)
(Drew clapping)
Now that we've realized
that there is a light around the corner,
we're gonna go back and do them.
Because we put too much work into it.
It's too much fun.
The audience had had had a blast.
So yes, we'll be back there. Thank you.
Well, I think New York is waiting
and very excited for that.
Me too. Thanks, Drew.
So hurry back.
Thank you, Grobanites.
Thank you, Josh.
This was so much fun.
Thank you, Drew.
"Harmony Deluxe" is out now.
That's right.
And Josh, this was so much fun. Thank you.
Drew. I love you.
You're crew has been
so incredible.
(audience clapping)
I can't wait for you to have a live audience again.
And I love you guys. Thank you for having me.
We love you too!
(audience cheering)
(upbeat music)